pendant les cinq années qui se sont
écoulées depuis la tragédie anne marie
saint cerny a fouillé et l'a écoutée
elle a assisté au procès et éplucher le
rapport d' enquête pour tenter de
retracer le fil des événements avant
pendant et après l'accident
elle vient de publier mégantic une
tragédie annoncée on la reçoit ce soir
madame st cerny vous vous êtes vous êtes
arrivé dans les jours qui ont suivi
cette tragédie en tant qu'activiste
environnementalistes et puis vous avez
tout de suite vous raconter dans votre
livre compris que vous alliez rester
pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous a à
lac-mégantic à tirer comme ça comment
avez vous su on devient sensible avec le
temps vous le savez et 47 morts à
mégantic les 16000 seize mille morts à
montréal c'est si gigantesque disparu en
quelques secondes et donc il était
évident pour moi qu'il fallait qu'on est
des vrais raisons qu'on aille au fond
des choses et par intuition par part à
cause de mon pas activée si je sentais
qu'on aurait pas les les bonnes réponses
qu'on n'irait pas au fond des choses et
les premières réponses qu'on a eus était
qu'il y avait quelqu'un en qui avait pas
mis à cette freins et cinq ans plus tard
c'est encore la réponse il y avait
quelqu'un en hockey pas mis assez de
près or c'est faux
vous parlez d'un accident mais ce que
j'ai découvert au cours des années
finalement est-ce que le corps anne
hardy sexy fait 47 morts évitables ce
n'est pas un accident c'est un lorsqu'on
dit rob la vie de quelqu'un c'est un
crime et je veux savoir ce qui s'est
passé et on n'ira pas de l'avant en
corse un contrat n'est sans le savoir et
sans changer ce qui a causé sa justement
malgré des appels répétés il ya toujours
pas eu de commission d' enquête publique
pour faire la lumière qu'est ce que
cette commission permettrait qu'est-ce
qu'on ne sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on
devrait savoir écouter c'est assez
hallucinant presque que la seule le seul
rapport qu'on a est un rapport du bst
qui est un rapport technique très le
bureau de
bureau de la sécurité des transports
mais alors qu'on peut avoir des
commissions d enquête sur le déclin du
saumon dans le pacifique
47 morts plus tard on a on s'en tient
toujours
c'est quelqu'un en qui a pas mis assez
de frais et d'ailleurs les seules
personnes qui ont accusé comme vous le
savez sont les trois employés de la mma
et donc on réalise quand on assiste au
procès quand tombent les peluches où et
quand on écoute tous les ministres après
l'autre que que finalement il ya
personne il ya personne qui enquêtent
personnes qui répondent autre chose que
il ya encore dernièrement le ministre
garneau en annonçant la voie de
contournement qui dit tout est réglé
c'est parfait la loi et sécuritaire et
malheureusement dans la dernière semaine
le meilleur la meilleure critique de
livre que j'aurais pu obtenir si le
bureau de sécurité des transports qui le
dit encore dernièrement que les
laiteries à la dérive était en hausse et
que s'il n'avait pas immédiatement
quelque chose qui se passait au niveau
de la loi
les accidents se répèterait de plus en
plus dramatique dans votre votre livre
qui se lit un peu comme un roman vous
avez tous énormément de liens pour
démontrer un peu ce qui s'était passé
auparavant ce qui avait mis en place
une situation peut-être que permis cette
tragédie à lac-mégantic qui vous montrer
du doigt les grands magna de la finance
vous faites beaucoup de lien entre ce
qui se passe à wall street par exemple
des décisions qui sont prises très loin
la réalité des gens de cette petite
communauté à lac mégantic et ce qui a
permis en quelque sorte cette tragédie
de se dérouler oui ces faits tragiques
et caricatural à la fois c'est une
histoire un peu trop moderne où ces gens
à wall street pour faire des milliards
de faire plusieurs centaines de millions
par année n'était pas suffisant que
l'enfer plusieurs milliards dans un an
et donc un bonhomme à tête argenté qu'il
ya des condos de 90 millions de dollars
à new york s'est associé avec des
dirigeants du cp qui ont des ranchs
inouïe sur pinto reste et sachant
parfaitement ce qu'il faisait ce sachant
parfaitement que les rails tiendrait pas
le coup ont armé des trains avec le
pétrole du dakota sacha aussi
parfaitement que c'était volatile que
c'était des bombes ambulantes
ils ont mis son art d'être est
extrêmement long extrêmement lourd et
envoyé ça en sous traitance un peu
partout à travers l'amérique y compris
chez mma qui était le pire
très compagnie ferroviaire au pire bilan
en amérique du nord
il savait parfaitement tout ça est la
question subsidiaire après ça est ce
cette partie être tragique loufoque et
est l'exemple même de ce qui se passe
sans arrêt mais la question subsidiaire
qui vient à préciser mais on est au
canada où était le gouvernement pour
pour surveiller ça et c'est là où la
réponse est sidérante
cinq ans plus tard vous avez aussi
témoigner de ce qu'on peut décrire
peut-être dans votre livre comme
poursuite d'une tragédie une tragédie
qui se poursuit pour la population de
lac mégantic
au niveau de la décontamination de la
reconstruction du centre ville des
mesures qui ont été adoptées avec cette
voie de contournement est ce que ce que
je leur en quoi est-ce que les gens
l'impression que ça s'est poursuivie
aussi après l' incendie
et puis les membres écoutez c'est pas la
tragédie mégantic ce sont les trajets
dit mégantic malheureusement que j'ai vu
se dérouler sous mes yeux
donc a eu le choc initial mais ensuite
qui a détruit son pare simplement au
niveau matériel 39 maisons mais les
décisions de l'amérique qui
essentiellement aux voulu gentrifié
moderniser sa ville a démoli 41-41
bâtiment je rappelle tout au long du
livre que les élus eux mêmes la bo était
le même en choc et qu'il va falloir
trouver des façons d'encadrer des élus
un choc lorsqu'il arrive une catastrophe
et il reste pas moins que les
expropriations sauvage les destructions
de maisons la destruction complète
centre-ville a causé énormément de
souffrance et même l'institut national
de santé publique le confirme c'est
celle de et avec lequel les migrants qui
ont le plus de problèmes et
malheureusement la voie de contournement
la très nécessaire voie de contournement
vient ajouter au problème encore parce
que elle jette les uns contre les autres
essentiellement les victimes pourquoi
parce que ce rail cette voie de
contournement va à part payé par nous
entièrement va appartenir à la compagnie
qu'il a dessiné la mais où elle veut et
le gouvernement n'impose pas de dire
vous allez vous asseoir avec les
citoyens et discuter pour trouver ou pas
c'est exactement exactement un troisième
2 anne marie saint cerny on va devant se
laisser là dessus je vous remercie
d'être venu je vous remercie infiniment